-We all know
how to play charades.
We're gonna do four rounds,
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams get the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
All right, Saoirse,
you're over here.
Come on.
-Where are we going? This way?
-Yeah, you're on that side.
All right now.
Here we go.
Come on. We got this.
What number, guys?
-Three!
[ Audience shouting "Three" ]
-Wow, everyone just said
"three."
"Three!" Everyone's like,
"Yeah, okay, cool, three."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-Telepathy, Jimmy.
Telepathy.
-We got this.
-We got this, pardsy.
Let's go. Ready?
-We'll soul brothers.
-All right, ready?
-Yeah.
Is it a song?
-Yes.
-It's a song.
-Okay.
-Okay, three words.
Okay.
First word, baby.
Third word.
"Baby Got Back."
-Yes, that's correct!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You want to go first?
Yeah, you go first.
That was too easy.
-Alessia --
No, Alessia, you're up first.
-Oh, I have to go first?
Oh, okay.
-Put the pressure on you.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Seven?
"Seven!"
Going for lucky number seven?
I feel like I'm on, like --
-"The Tonight Show"!
-Come on!
No, I don't want this one.
I don't want this one.
-Alessia, you have to do it.
-Exactly.
-I don't want this one.
-You have to do it.
-Don't show us, though.
-All right.
Okay, so it's...
-TV.
-Okay.
-Four words.
-Is this timed? We have time?
-Yes!
-Oh, shoot. Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Um, um, um -- come on!
Okay, okay, thir-- oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Third word.
-Um...
-Fighting.
Ninja warrior.
Ninja -- Teenage Mutant Ninja --
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Yes! Okay.
I never thought
you were gonna get that.
-That is rigged!
-It's fun! It's fun.
-That's fun.
How did you get that
and then you end up
with a floss at the end?
-That was amazing.
-It's fine.
-Just be chill.
-All right, sorry.
I'm gonna be cool.
-All right?
-I'm gonna be cool.
-We're winners.
-All right, we're winners.
Here we go.
[ Audience shouting ]
-I see -- I see a two.
Oh!
-That's good.
-Don't look!
-Disqualified.
-What we do?
-That's a point off.
-We'll take two.
-Okay.
-We're winners. Here we go.
-We're champions.
-Right.
-Legends.
Movie.
-Okay. Um...
-Two words.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Second word.
-Yeah.
-Me.
You.
Me.
Boy. Boy.
Man.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
Fly man?
Oh, Spider-Man?
Oh, Batman.
Gosh, I can't think of --
Ant-Man!
-Yes!
-Yes! Ant-Man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anderson,
let's see what you got.
-What are we gonna
do about this?
-You can do that.
Do you want to do that one?
-Don't look, don't look.
-Do you want to do that one?
-No.
No, we don't do the fallen one.
-All right.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Yeah?
-Got this.
-All right.
-It's easy.
-I don't know. Okay.
-Okay.
-No, me, me, me. Not --
-Okay, it's a song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Three words.
Um...
Shoot.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Uh...
-First word.
Third word.
Cry.
-Mm-hmm.
-Bird?
[ Light laughter ]
Pray?
Cry.
Fly, cry --
I don't know!
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-"Living on a Prayer"?
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
-"When Doves Cry"?
-"When Doves Cry"!
[ Ding! ]
-Prince!
-No.
-He had the moves, then pointed.
-I was trying to do the ass --
-He was pointing
at the butt cheeks.
That was a good move.
-Wow, I'm sorry.
-I should've
showed my butt cheeks.
-Yeah, you should have.
That would have --
-I got it.
-Damn.
Here we go.
You guys have a chance.
This is the final round.
-Wait.
So are we tied?
-No, we're in the lead,
but, Saoirse and Alessia,
you guys are gonna get
the same clue at the same time,
and whatever team gets it,
wins the whole game.
We get to guess,
you guys get to do the charades.
-Oh.
-So we have to do the same one?
-Yep.
-Okay. What number do you want?
[ Audience shouting ]
She does have moves.
-Let's do 5.
-5, yeah.
-I saw the moves.
-Oh.
[ Laughing ]
-Okay, wait.
One, two, three, four, five.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Ready?
-Pal, we got this.
-Wait. Are we going?
-Yeah, we're going!
-Okay.
-First word.
Bang.
-Last word.
-Open. Drop.
-First word.
Uh, fall.
Uh...
-Five.
Fifth word.
Taste.
-Drop.
-Sizzle.
-Drop --
-"Drop it like it's hot"!
Ohh! Ohh! Ohh!
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
Ohh, my goodness!
-Hold on!
-♪♪ Drop it like it's hot ♪♪
♪♪ Drop it like it's hot ♪♪
Yes, yes!
Whoo!
Our thanks to Saoirse Ronan,
Alessia Cara, Anderson .Paak.
[ Cheers and applause ]